carl jung talked about this phenomena he
cried phenomenon he described as a
retrogressive restoration of the persona
and so it's a complicated idea but
basically what it means is that
sometimes you take a leap forward and
you learn some things but you can't
catalyze a new identity so you try to go
back and hide in your old identity and
that actually doesn't work because well
things have changed and you've learned
something and that isn't who you are
anymore and so it's like you have to cut
part parts of yourself off in a
destructive manner to fit back into the
person that you were now what happens
here is that Pinocchio escapes from this
tyrannical situation and undergoes this
descend into chaos but he tries to go
back home he tries to go back to what he
was and he can't do that anymore his
father isn't at home anymore and so so
when he goes home he finds that there's
no home there now this happens to people
sometimes it's often a shock to them so
one of the things I've noticed about
peterpan type I'm going to speak about
men here because I served it more and
man is that they often stay under the
thumb of their father and you think well
why would someone do that because it
means they're subject to the tyrannical
judgment of their father they're always
concerned about what their father would
think or whether their father approves
of them of them and so forth and you
think well that's going to be an
unpleasant place to be why would you do
that one of the things that I've
suggested to my clients and other people
sometimes is that here's a weird little
exercise that you can undertake a little
thought experiment so you have your
parents and of course your parents have
friends who are about their age and
maybe some of them are people you only
know peripherally
and I might ask you well do you care
more about what your parents think then
you care about what these peripheral
people who know your parents think and
then the answer to that is well of
course and then the question that arises
out of that is why I mean for someone
else your parents are the peripheral
people and their parents are central
like why is it logical that your parents
make opinion makes any more difference
to you than the appearance than the the
opinion of some randomly selected people
who are approximately that age why is it
the case that you would consider that
they would know more than someone else I
mean I know they know you better and
fair enough but that that's not the
point
and then another point there is that to
the degree that your parents opinion
about you matters more than some
randomly selected people of
approximately the same age you would say
well you haven't exactly separated out
the gaudy image from your parents and so
you're still under that that combination
it's like it's a complicated thing to
talk about but think about the Harry
Potter series Harry has two sets of
parents right he's got the Dursley
parents and then he's got these like
magical parents that sort of float
behind and he should know the difference
between them they shouldn't be one in
the same they're not for him and it's
like well you have your parents and you
have nature and culture as parents and
you shouldn't be thinking that your
parents are nature and culture as well
you shouldn't have final dominion over
you means that you're not an individual
yet if that's the case Freud said for
example that no no no one could be a man
unless his father had died and Jung said
yes but that death can take place
symbolically okay so there's that part
of the idea and then another part of the
idea is one of the times in your life
when you actually realize that you're an
individual is when you'll go and ask
your parents something and you realize
they actually don't know any more about
what you should do then you do and that
sucks and that's partly why people are
often willing to maintain a tyrant slave
relationship with their father it's like
on the one hand you have to be inferior
in a relationship
like that you know you've always got the
judge watching you but another hand
there's always someone who knows what to
do there's always someone standing
between you and the unknown that you can
go ask what should I do well at some
point you'll realize that the reason you
can't ask that anymore is because they
actually don't know any more than you do
and then that's a pain like that that is
a symbolic death that's also when you
establish a more individual relationship
with your parents it's at that point
that you could conceivably start taking
care of them instead of the reverse and
that's the time that should come but you
have to let that image of perfection go
and that exposes you well that's what
happens here
you know Pinocchio goes home and he
wants things to be the way they were and
he wants to stay under the careful care
of the benevolent father but that's no
longer possible he's past that point and
that's why the father has disappeared
and so Geppetto has gone off to look for
Pinocchio because he also needs a son
but but in any case the house is
abandoned and so then there we see
inside the house that everything's
covered with cobwebs and everything's
gone and Pinocchio and the crickets sit
on the steps and they're very concerned
first of all they wonder where he went
so they're actually concerned that he's
gone but they also don't know what to do
because there's just no going home and
so you know that's also the case that
once you hit a certain point in your
development well it's the same thing we
already talked about the answers that
you're looking for are not going to be
found in your parents house it's as
simple as that now you could
artificially maintain your dependency
but you know if you do that for too long
things get pretty ugly so you get pretty
stale and and you know you're like bread
that's been on the Shelf for too long